or certain host
oh we're live
oh yay
okay uh guys one in the chat if we're if
we're live because I wanna we're kind of
have issues I was gone that would be
nice okay all right what up guys welcome
to the just pearly things YouTube
channel and welcome to my interview
series welcome zerka to the show
thank you for having me Pearl
um so I wanted to invite Circa on today
because he literally has been taking
over the manosphere by storm
um I have been seeing you go viral
basically everywhere all over the
manosphere and like where where did you
come from
who are you
who am I yeah I'm CIA your CIA
yes they put me on the algorithm
I'm uh
well I started the internet thing on a
dating show called the Raj Patel where
where this Jewish guy would pretend to
be an Indian and so it turned into the
Austin show but
yeah they they found me they scouted
they're like Talent scouting on the
internet and they found me and they put
me on and then I pulled the gun on the
girls on the e-date
and then I got like a half a million
hits and that's how I started and then
well you pulled the game on a girl on a
date
all four of them
and they freaked out but it's like on a
webcam I can't even kill them you know
okay so it was an e day and you pulled a
gun on them and then they break down
yeah yeah and the clip went big and then
they almost kicked me off and then I
knew I had to win them over and stay on
the show and milk it and then uh every
time I was breaking like 3K 4K views
they would ban me and I needed money so
I would do like low quality stuff at a
thousand viewers just to get my sub
count up to like twenty thousand dollars
a month I was trying to make that was
like my goal and I hit that for a long
time
on YouTube or twitch
on on Twitch because uh yeah they said
as long as I'm like a low-level twitch
streamer they won't ban me like that's
kind of how it goes if you have too much
influence and you do a lot of my gun
crazy [__] they'll they'll can your ass
so I said I'll just stay in my corner
with my community at a thousand viewers
and make money I made my money and then
they Banned Me again permanently
and I'm like the most bad streamer on
the website like there's streamers
who've had bomb threats
to get a Perma band but all I did was
like make jokes and I got permaband in
my first week what did you so yeah don't
don't say the joke okay don't don't say
the joke oh what did you get banned for
like what type of joke was it
we don't know but I was pretty much
saying the stuff I say to women on fresh
and Fit I was saying get on those
left-leaning shows oh I see
yeah yeah and then I got a lot of DMS
really weird DMS from the girls who were
trying to [__] me they would screenshot
the twitch admins that would flirt with
them and how they like inspired to keep
me banned if you if you stay around
Circa we're gonna ban him and stuff and
I had no idea that it's like that
personal
and so uh I laid low you know and even
my brother and friends are like dude you
don't have you can't go back to a
regular life after these kind of Clips
you're not gonna go back to Security
State a thousand viewers do reactionary
just react content and because you know
I'm my community is very generous and so
I would just do that and heaps of money
from especially for what I'm used to
and then you know I was always
frustrated because I'm like man I can
never actually do this bigger streams
like I'd be afraid anytime the viewer
can will go up to 2K I start having
anxiety I'll be like oh [__] here comes
another four month break from this [__]
what type of content were you reacting
to is it red pill or was it more like
conservative content
you mostly it was red pill and dating
because uh when I did IRL picking up
women
I was picking them picking them up in
like eight seconds for big fat donations
and they're like can you break down what
you're doing because uh it looks like
[__] for his like it looks like I'm
just winging it but it's instinct to me
because I worked at clubs for five years
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday for eight hours a night
so all I did is like
that even the nights I because I was
like anti-social even the nights I
didn't talk to girls and stuff I would
study the guys who did talk to them and
I'd pick up on their habits and I you
know I would study that's all I ever
wanted when I was young is like women
because I lost my Virginia 20. so I was
like an adult who couldn't talk to women
I was like oh [__] I gotta learn this
and my buddies would make fun of me and
I'm very competitive so you know I was
like oh [__] you're at a 30 body count
you're at a 20 I'm at zero and they're
all laughing at me and then I played
ketchup in one summer and then had like
a head count of like a thousand girls
gave me head and that was concerned when
I was 20 and one in one summer
no it was like almost a year and a half
for that so in a year and a half but uh
you hooked up with a thousand chicks
easily yeah but it was uh only had never
ever risked pregnancy or any of that
because I had big four years of that
and uh and first but it wasn't like I
was into women like that it was more
like getting a lot of girls in my city
got me invited to the bigger parties and
the bigger paychecks right they'd be
like here's two thousand dollars come
with these rappers bring the girls we'll
give you two thousand dollars on the low
and so I could finally start making some
extra money because I was a bad drug
dealer in the beginning
and uh so I would use the women like as
currency really okay so so you were 20
years old and this is in Canada right
okay so so you were in Canada
um and you're a virgin at 20
and then you realized you were bad with
women and so then in a year and a half
in order to sell drugs
you slept with a thousand with it it
sounds crazy but that's exactly how it
went so you could go to it
basically when you're when you're when I
had women all around me following me in
town the Hell's Angels or the Immigrant
gangs they would bring me hey come to
the penthouse and these guys were like
we're very rich and then they knew I'm
not coming for free so they treated us
like a host they'd say I'm security but
really I would bring the party and uh
yeah it was like just Charming the girls
and then bringing them there
and uh yeah a lot of extra money like
that and but really I just want to get
connected so I could move more into
drugs yeah
okay so so were you doing security at
the same time or no
yeah so straight from my shift at work
uh I spent four and a half or five you
know five years almost
I didn't see daylight for five years
that's imagine a depressed man not
seeing day left for five years or
friends or family because I'd always be
sleeping the day because of like all the
night jobs
and uh
I loved it you know because I was like
daytime people look like civilians who
want to put me in jail for the things I
say nighttime people like understood me
but they're all demonic they're like
most of them are in jail now
all the night time like all the people
used to hang out with aren't you all my
friends I grew up with are either in
jail or waiting for their day they have
to go wow
wow and did you ever get in trouble for
it like did you ever get caught selling
drugs
well I got in a lot of trouble with the
law but never for that because uh when I
was driving around and moving stuff I
would be clean-shaping in a suit and tie
and look like a white guy because I was
so obsessed with politics Optics the
stuff that I do on my stream I would
just notice that hey at a checkpoint or
if there's doing a traffic stop the
white guy in a suit and tie would get
away with murder
so I wasn't like in a hoodie and looking
like gangster and [__] and then when I
got tattooed on the hand and I'd stick
my hand out on the [__] you know
driving I'd stick it out I had no idea
how much [__] trouble you get in for
hand ink like you should start getting
pulled over for no reason and yeah that
really like red filled me on Optics is
everything and another thing was I'd
have an earpiece uh at work and I
wouldn't take it off so I can go into
any event because I would walk up to the
door and be like where's Selena we gotta
go now oh [__] he works here he's an
authority and I'd walk into big rapper
shows for like no one would stop me
because I'd be so aggressive like they
think I'm an authority because I have a
[__] earpiece and I don't even work
at these events I was just trying to get
connected with people and so then I
realized like oh that's a strong
marketing strategy that if I get on the
internet and I'm the authority people
just collab with me and they go oh [__]
and so it even my first day on the
internet I was like I'm the [__] and
then they're like oh we believe you but
I was nothing right
okay wait so how long
when did you stop doing the drug dealing
like how long did that go on for I
thought you were gonna say when did you
stop doing the drugs because that's a
different question uh the drug dealing I
stopped after my first prayer to go
viral when it worked I didn't make money
but well I did make money but like it
wasn't sustainable right it's just
internet stuff
but I said like if God gave me this life
and I drug deal with it obviously I'm
gonna get punished which is so it's so
tempting when you're the most popular
guy in your city because you're on
YouTube and twitch to drug deal because
everyone wants it from you because they
kind of just want to get on your stream
and [__] so that was the most attempted
I've ever been is like I could make so
much if I do both like stream and you
come to my house pick up off me but I'll
do only one and I was making like maybe
after the bands there's like 4 000 a
month in the beginning I was really bad
at the streaming thing and then uh I
worked my way up to like 20 000 a month
and I was doing good
and uh yeah right so so I'm just trying
to get the timeline here so you were
doing balancing until you were like how
old
24 and then I went viral on my 25th okay
and you're like 31 now right
no I just turned 29. oh okay I thought I
was close I was close sorry
um okay so you're 29. so then would it
what what if the last four years looked
like for you since since quitting quit
walking away from drug dealing
well I had a lot of weird arcs like I
had a year and a half during covet since
I couldn't stay with my friends like I
can't stay with these drug dealers
because I didn't want twitch people to
know that I've done people I was already
blackballed I didn't want to get
blackballed more so I just stay in my
room and I wouldn't date because like
I've never made money when I would have
like a a woman around me so I spent a
year and a half during the covet
lockdown alone in the room streaming 22
hours a day getting every dollar I could
and then that was my first celibacy run
you stream for 22 hours a day
way more than that like if you could
Google these hours like I was and I was
speaking at this speed this pace this
this loudness for 22 hours straight I
wasn't like playing a game I was yeah so
I was like XGC times four like I was
some of the people in chat were there
for that and I loved it because I'm like
oh I'm not doing construction or
security this is easy
and uh and what made it easy was my
community so toxic that when I'm not
brigading other channels and hurting
people's feelings when they're just
chilling with me we get away with all
the [__] crazy [__] I say so it was
like laughing I would be laughing for 22
hours straight with them like every day
I'm sorry
I was gonna say that was my first time
doing from deviant life with women to
celibacy one year and a half the very
spiritual experience for me right no
porn I would fact sometimes when I'd
break I'd break the code and fat but I
was so busy with streaming that I like
wouldn't think about it and that was my
first Purity like uh as an adult my
first pure year and a half you know what
I mean yeah and then uh and then I
ruined it by partying yeah I get a
little confused with you I won't lie I
get a little bit Yeah I have arms that's
why because there's a a bunch of people
in my community remember my pure Arc and
they're like we need you to be there so
they hate when hoes are around me and
then some of the guys who are like just
here for the pickup advice they like the
girls around me so it's like I have like
a divided oh yeah well I get confused
because like on one stream you'll be
talking about Catholicism
and I'm Catholic you know so I'm like
good way to go you know but then the
next stream I'll hear you talking about
doing coke so I get a bit confused like
how would you say you're religious
yes but I would say I'm so religious I'm
hyper focused on my yes meaning yes and
my no meaning no because God rewards the
[__] out of me when I'm very honest like
uh
I've incriminated myself telling these
stories online which you're not supposed
to do for future brand deals and
sponsorships but my life is blessed when
I just say it how it is I say the truth
and anytime I've ever pulled back 20
percent
bad things would happen to me like even
if I was making money I would feel I had
like an identity crisis of oh am I an
influence are my gay influencer and [__]
so I was like I can't be happy unless
I'm telling the truth and I'm not saying
that like how all influencers say that I
mean like I actually tell the truth if
you watch my content you'll cringe
you'll be like whoa he's going way too
hard like I say I'm not saying it's the
truth I'm saying it's exactly what I'm
thinking I mean yeah well I would never
claim that it's the truth like that but
it's exactly what I'm thinking I mean I
see that on Twitter you'll just like
take you'll have a girl in your bed and
you'll just you'll just tweet her
yeah because there's this dark stomach
feeling I used to get when I hook up
with a girl or go on a date and then I
go live and talk about Christianity and
I'm like
if someone takes a photo with me in one
of these hoes
the level of Shame I'm not Hassan [__]
where I don't feel shame I feel a lot of
Shame if I'm hiding in the shadows
you know I don't want to ever get gone
so I get myself you know I leak my DMs I
do everything if I tell a girl you're a
useless piece of trash get the [__] out
of here I actually showed the text so
she can never cancel me I leaked it
first I never want to like
lose sleep being like Oh what if that
[__] leaks me saying something mean so
I'm like I'll do it I'll I'll just leak
everything and then uh yeah it works for
me but but you'd consider yourself
Catholic right is that what it was okay
when have you always been Catholic or is
that a new thing
no I'm from a Muslim family I converted
after my prayer worked but not as a
Catholic I just believed in God and I
would be too afraid to say Christ
because I I didn't want to do like I
read the Bible but I never went in depth
like reading the Bible doesn't mean you
read it like
it's pondering and debating it that gets
gets your you know gets you understand
scripture wait so you uh it's so
interesting cause all the red pill guys
are going from like Christian or
Catholic to Muslim and you actually went
the opposite
yeah yeah and it's because I for the
first time in my life I started reading
books a year ago uh my twin brother he's
a therapist he said something on stream
that gave me like I never get anxiety I
could do Coke and I don't get anxiety
right I could do crack but he said on
stream as a joke I will always be
remembered for
picking up women like if I was to leave
the internet and I remember like with
all this money I made and like fixed my
life I was like looking at myself like
I'm a homosexual if that's what I'm
going to be remembered for
and then I'm like what else am I known
for and he said oh yeah you do
conspiracy and esoteric and I'm like
yeah but did I master that like Alex
Jones supposedly did no [__] it I'm
gonna start reading books and so I took
a bunch of time off work like eight
months like on and off screens to travel
with my girlfriend resorts in hotels and
I'll just finish all these books and I
would be pouring through these books and
my viewer account went from two thousand
viewers to 400 people hated these books
they hated the topics you know it was a
little way too mature of a subject it's
like Scholars read these books and it's
definitely not like Circle content but I
needed it because I never had college or
anything I was a drop up
and uh these books are like people who
work in the Federal Reserve and treasury
or Freemasons these are monitors and
freemasonic books so I would finish them
and that's what led me to Christ because
I was always watching the pastors on the
internet and rooting for the Christian I
don't know why there's like the
character I liked it his name was Pastor
David Lynn it's the first one I watched
and
so when I finished all these books of
like the ruling class and how they they
control the world
and yeah it led me to Christ because uh
even they believe Christ is real they
just don't like him they don't they
think Lucifer is the supreme authority
which I always thought there are
atheists so I'm like okay if these
because it really I want a Billionaire's
opinion I don't want like some [__]
Jordan Peterson's opinion so I would
read these books and every single one of
them was like reverse engineering the
Bible for their Lucifer in Utopia or
satanic Utopia depending if they go left
or right hand path of their Kabbalah
Majesty
and so I'm like holy [__] the Bible's
actually real and then I started really
uh seeing connections with like Adam and
Eve well you know what what's the
building blocks of life Adams and I'm
like whoa what the [__]
uh and I would see uh the michikaku the
Japanese scientist he said
uh he's a excuse me he's a physicist
famous Japanese physicist American
Japanese physicist he said it's
interesting how String Theory exactly
mirrors the Zohar and Kabbalah ancient
Jewish mysticism
from thousands of years ago String
Theory I'm like okay here's another
scientist and as a flat earther I knew
God's real because uh oh yeah they're
all you're a flat earther
yeah that's how I got 40 000 followers
is beating Destiny in a flat Earth
debate so I was a flat earther without
Christ it's kind of weird okay you know
because I was really a flat earther
because the scientific method the
Michelson Morley experiments all of that
uh was on the flat earth side so people
be like you just believe in flatters
because you're a Christian I'd be like
no [__] what the [__] it's because the
scientific methods on our side with
eight inches per mile square of
curvature calculations and how how high
are people on altitude until you see a
curved Earth you never see it unless
it's a warped fish eye wide angle lens
so I was like
halfway there spiritually and I just
couldn't get on board with the Christ
thing at all but I would root for the
Christians you know these are I [__]
with them hard and I love Twilight Zone
in the 1950s so much when things were
sexist I watched every episode I'm like
that's the side that's the society I
love Sharia law but that's the society I
want to be a part of with my top hat and
my anti-Semitism I'm kidding so
I would watch all that black and white
stuff I usually watch it with my mom
when I was younger right
and it would all this resurface every
time I had a horrible relationship with
a girl like even the good conservative
girls were liberal the liberal ones were
Wars so I was like whoa it's not really
the women's fault they're like 80 of
marketing is catered to the woman you
guys hold the credit cards so they're
[__] from an early age they're
brainwashed at an early age so I'm
inheriting what is this liberalism and I
find out this isn't really just about
what private property and [__] free
trade the word Liberty comes to be
liberated it's an Enlightenment word to
be liberated
from God's law that's that's where the
word comes from as in the alternative
was a Christian theocracy and then how
they got rid of that was with liberalism
so it's literally wait what are you
sorry I don't know much about about this
so
like what do you mean by Christian
theocracy
uh basically the word Liberty comes from
stripping away a do you know what Sharia
law is
um that's like uh that's like a Muslim
thing it's don't don't roast me chat
that's like a Muslim thing yeah yeah
it's like no pork or something right
Sharia law would be like pretty much
um the their religion is over the state
right it's like the religion rules oh
okay
yeah and so the op the Christian version
of that where it's just a Christian
state right off of the biblical laws not
these judicial gay laws that the
biblical laws right that's what they had
before the Enlightenment and so when I
was researching history because I don't
know any of this [__] and I'm like dude
I'm like turning 27 I don't know any of
this [__]
and I'm going year after year and trying
to like really like you know expand my
brain because you know I've never read
books so I'm like I want to be you know
caught up to speed so I can sound like
coherent when I talk about this [__]
and it turns out that all the Geniuses
throughout history like DaVinci and all
of them their breeding ground where they
develop the atmosphere was a Christian
world
so I'm like the Christian World brought
because we're taught that those
Enlightenment atheists and agnostics are
all just homosexuals who don't believe
in God and that's why they're so smart
not really they grew up in the Christian
atmosphere right they grew up in the
Christian realm that's what allowed them
to be Geniuses they didn't grow up in
degenerate Miami right and so I'm like
whoa so obserka grew up in those times I
would be way different of a person we'd
all be a thousand IQ points higher and
so that was very red pilling to me that
I'm like oh it's not just a book
the final book I finished was the morals
and Dogma I didn't get it no one gets it
Scholars don't get it and it's like very
poetic too and it's written by the grand
wizard Albert Pike the general American
General who predicted the three Wars and
what's to come in the future and in his
book
his book pretty much after I finished it
10 times and I would sleep do it and I
would like draw pictures to try and
understand that comic books and stuff
when I finally understood morals and
Dogma
it really hammered the point that I mean
he there is even I forget which page he
says the two most important books on
Earth will be the Bible and the Zohar
right which is good and bad what's this
oh it's Jewish witchcraft I don't want
to get into it
yeah I have disavowed and so then I
would read these uh I would read like
Manny P hall and how he had that
mysterious death and his audio biography
apparently he would just sit down like
Jordan Peterson and he'd give a speech
looking at a wall like he's in a psychic
trance-like State like Freemasons enter
and those non-ordinary States and I
watched there's some of his on YouTube
and you talk about magic and I'm like
why is it genius like he's a thousand
times Jordan Peterson Peterson's talking
about gay ass Harry Potter [__] and
Magic but he would break it down as a
cult science and uh controlling the
invisible forces of nature and and how
most people who get into it regret it
because as soon as they find out they're
psychically they can psychically
influence someone to fall in love with
them or something
they immediately get paranoid and think
whoa what's happening to me in the
mental plane who is psychically uh
affecting me and that's how
most people who get into occult
scientists actually lose their minds and
they all do it for passion you either do
it for passion or compassion which are
both kind of wrong
um but one is way more wrong than the
other and uh it'd be called Black Magic
and I and it is a form of spell casting
I mean the best way I describe it is Kim
zerka draw a spell on a piece of paper
and start a riot yes I could draw
swastika walk in a synagogue right now
and start a riot I could do a BLM shirt
with George George Floyd sucking a [__]
and I could start a riot so spell
casting does exist into the mental plane
and that's why Freemasons say signs and
symbols rule the world uh and so did
Nicholas Tesla and uh
yeah so so basically the last year I had
traveling with my girlfriend uh my
content really shifted into like more
in-depth esoteric and I would mix it
with politics because it just makes more
sense when you do it like that to
explain the world
and then there's a lot of people
attacking me who are like oh as soon as
you study black magic he started going
viral so this guy's like a double agent
blah blah which is not true I don't
practice any of that but it's real the
most influential man in history uh well
in recent history is Aleister Crowley
and he's known for writing poetry about
anal sex and vomiting on a woman and
then making her eat it I don't know who
that is that's the most famous man in
history
no he's one of he's one of the most
influential guys who like uh he inspired
the Beatles and all those kind of
satanic rock groups and it's funny The
Beatles actually have an album called
The Past Masters Past Masters is a rank
in Freemasonry and they have like
pictures with the upside down cross and
how their goal was to eradicate
Christianity
and yeah everything from the 1960s
sexual Revolution where they brought the
peace sign which is the cross upside
down but broken snapped in half
all that was like a supercharged new
Enlightenment a new Enlightenment into
this degenerate World We inherited now
we're in a world where everyone's girl
has cheated or even emotionally cheated
which is do you know how much sin that
is in the world and yeah so actually I
think after last
I I think about how even um I I didn't
realize that women like
one of the most inverse like um stats
for us having children is like going to
college
did you know that
um going to college is bad right yeah
like it makes women have less kids I
didn't realize that so when you were
saying like even the conservative women
are like liberal in a way
um it's like if you go to college in a
way you're kind of living life like a
liberal when you think about it
I mean
really
women Cancer all of this but
all of their missing all of their
mystery and this is just comedy I don't
want to like Nuke anyone's Channel but
all of their mystery comes from wanting
to be cool in status with men when
really it's like
what woman is gonna work 60 years of her
life straight I don't do we know a woman
like that that never happened and Men
worked 60 years straight with a smile on
their face but when you think about it
it's like women set themselves up for
failure with this terrible feminism and
it's too late we've made our own bed so
it's like
we're about to see some of the worst
kind of civil unrest coming in the
future and uh for thousands of years we
protected women's innocence of virginity
not just as like all the man gets a
virgin
being the [__] in society really [__]
up the world faster than anything
right because men surprise is not their
career it's their wife that's why they
have a career no one has a wife and if
they do she's not a virgin
so there's immediate distrust in the
relationship psychically in the
subconscious and I'm sure he thinks
about it sometimes consciously too how
am I doing you're doing good you're
echoing a bit in this room just you know
it's a bit actually
what if I open the door uh it's a little
better
um
no I was actually because when I first
saw a certain Brad pill content kind of
like like I would hear guys be like
women are [__] and like like I would
hear the guys like I know I know I know
that's not but then I would look at the
stats and I was like I can't really
complain about I can't really say
they're not right when it's like one out
of four of us has an STD one out of
three of us has had an abortion 90 of us
have been on birth control it's like
you know it you might not have an of but
like in in terms of like women
throughout history
you know the average chick today it's
it's it's it's it's sad but you know I
can't even I can't even fault the guys
for it
and psychically they're programmed to
say well what about you and your body
count Circle forget me let's look at the
average guy right
see what I did no no but no I'm going
somewhere with this hold on it's I'll
come back to me
so if the woman is the prize and the man
nobody wants him unless he's like really
popping
you guys can get [__] a lot the boy
he's trying to even if he's a player
he's not dude everyone goes to the woman
like every even if she's like mid
everyone DMS her a lot of Chads don't
even get four DMS a day you know what I
mean so I'm like it's way more dangerous
for them to be sexually liberated than
us
and even me when I was like I'm an okay
looking guy at 19.
I had zero DMS so I need zero DMS uh I I
used to like add random people on
Facebook to look more popular so some
girl would be like oh Aldi never
happened
then I got a job never happened and I
make money in sales never happened
dude if a child is having trouble like
me and I wasn't like awkward talking to
them what's just normal
then what's gonna happen with all these
other chats mid guys and stuff like are
they gonna like start a revolution
no they're gonna do a genocide on
themselves they're gonna kill themselves
right
purchasing power for both genders
increased so much but to spare
depression anxiety skyrocketed and meant
killing themselves so much now and
they're trying to stay it's not that bad
it's not that bad it's capitalism bro
you have an iPhone don't fill yourself
are you kidding I'm like I have a great
life and I don't like going into the
Wilderness because I see beasts and [__]
in this Beast system imagine you're just
a regular guy you must hate it and let
me grab a cigarette hold on wait I'm
[__] living Compton right now right
bro yeah I know you're doing great
guys one in the chat if he's doing great
make sure you like the video
um we have over 2
over people watching so let's try to get
to
I don't know 1500 likes I feel like
that's reasonable it's reasonable uh
blessing says a thousand likes will open
up the chat
um
it pushes me in the algorithm what
like the video because it pushes me in
the algorithm that way I can talk to
Logan Paul your favorite influencers
um the other thing like when I was
getting into red pill content and like
watching it like at first it was it was
really hard for me to watch as a girl
I'm like what do you mean we ate [__]
but it's like the numbers just back you
guys up so much you can't deny it it's
like throughout most of History women
were very like a hundred years ago 85
only 15 of women admitted to premarital
sex 15 100 years ago
um yeah and so let's say they're big
Liars right women always lie so let's
just double it and say say it's the it's
really 30 you know what they say like to
double it or whatever okay but that's
still two out of three
that were virgins on their wedding
nights and that was a hundred years ago
and that was actually when um
that that was still like the start of
feminism because feminism really started
like it had like people think it started
in like the 60s but it was really you
probably know this but it was like a
hundred it was before that so I would
imagine a hundred years earlier it was
last go ahead
I'm I'm a Catholic so I really believe
that Lou Harris jws were here thousands
of years ago Jezebel's Fierce earrings
and make cup [__] I mean they've been
with us trying to attend men for the
longest time and before Christianity
it was like they were like raping doing
molesting little boys and little girls
on Temple Pagan steps and everyone was a
[__] and stuff like that and then
Christianity would when they boomed and
it would go away and then boom and then
you know how it goes like a wave
it's always been there I feel like it's
always like horse Society has always
been here but right now it's the peak
because I actually got it wrong it's not
10 times women are 20 times less horny
than men and they closed the gap on
cheating for the first time in history
they're closing the Gap right now
they're about to do it so right now
would be the most accessibility in
recorded history which I don't know
because history Institute and crime is
warped but I do believe this like
[__] end times it's the worst we've
ever seen it and another thing is like
women shouldn't be afraid to go red
because
let's say they were red pill at 17 which
is [__] impossible
what's the byproduct of that
some model woman would keep her
virginity until 24 25 and marry a
billionaire so if you want to do only
for a hundred thousand dollars she's
gonna do like a million dollars in 10
years she would get everything and
probably even a chat
should have everything so if women were
red they gained the most from being read
they gained the most and they think it's
like we want them to be read so they can
[__] cook and clean and [__] like
that
dude
they're it's like uh when Martin said on
the show
you haven't met your man and you're 26.
did you have a better chance of meeting
your husband at 22 or 26. and I was like
dude
women need to at 22 they should be
locking up that man like you these men
are like sense they fall in love so
quick it's very easy to do but they're
like I'll do it after the only kind of
stuff and it's like no no that's when
the wave of competition enters that's
very dangerous to do and then you look
at men like be in a suit and tie in 35
I'll have even more women than right now
you know my value don't change well it
just goes up
and do you feel like you're always red
pill or did you have like a red pill
moment
uh they're telling you that they're
telling you to move closer to the mic
that's what they're saying okay
I feel like yeah I used to get suspended
in elementary school because I could not
imagine a woman playing a video game so
anytime
and anytime I play an MMO and I have a
girlfriend in the MMO I would never
assume it's a man
I
mean I would assume it's a man I'd be
like oh it's a dude right because I
couldn't fathom that a woman knows what
maple story or World of Warcraft or
something like that they don't they just
like Barbies and stuff so I was always
really like sexist like that in my head
or sexist
but I wasn't vocal I was like a quiet
kid and then when I got in the dating
world I tried the equality thing and uh
you know that's how I lost like the
first love of my life I was like whoa
they get so aggressive when they have
leverage but when they're under you
they're just like John let's get ice
cream and [__]
and uh
and yeah when I was like the most toxic
masculine my city like 22 years old 23
24. I had all the women and I was like
just like some dude on a couch selling
drugs
so I was like wow the missing variable
has to because these are models I'm
working with veterans good looking guys
six four Jack guys uh but I was thinking
all the women and the only thing I was
known as a drug dealer
was like that's the most sexist guy I
had like the worst reputation but I had
all the girls and the guys never copied
me they were so they're still so afraid
of women then I got on Twitch and
there's people with millions of
followers and I'm cooking them at
parties
so I was like you know I don't really
think I'm sexist and even if I didn't
believe any of this [__] let's say I
wasn't like biblical or any of that
I don't think I'll change because I
would lose 500 women in my life if I
became anything softer than this version
and this is the softest version I used
to be way worse so I'm like
do people really think
I'm just getting lucky there's so many
Chads with million followers who don't
do what I do they could never do any of
this stuff even the funny ones
I think the missing variable is when
when masculinity is scarce toxic
masculinity is the greatest magnet for
the woman and I went on that show fresh
bit and she said yeah is that kid
needing I would never date someone like
you you're this you're that and totally
embarrassed me and I called her a [__]
for three hours straight and then she's
in my bed lingerie right
no okay I noticed that at shows actually
when I would when I would um like do the
shows in London
um the the feminists that would like be
arguing with the guy after that I always
try to sleep with them like it would
happen every single time and that's why
I was like you guys were just like going
at each other now you're trying to go
home with like I don't know
yeah and I I I've asked a lot of girls
in the more intimate settings where they
can be honest and they've all kind of
said the same answer where it's like as
much as I hate what you talk about I
feel safe around you the other people
like those things the Google guys they
feel like those guys are gonna do
something to them in the hotel room and
stuff
and uh because now if someone's just
being unapologetically honest he's more
trustful well and like a lot of the blue
pill like I realized like so many guys
just lie they just Pander and they just
simply what
you're saying Destiny I did not say any
names
all right you know what's funny I wasn't
even thinking of Destiny um I was more
thinking of like guys on my show that
they've literally argued they don't care
about body count and I'm just like you
guys are just saying that so you can
sleep with the girls on the show it's so
disingenuous like I know what they're
doing and I and I don't like it because
it's not honest it's like you know that
if you when you're looking like because
it's like younger guys in their 20s
they're like oh I don't care but they're
not looking for a wife
yeah
and and you're talking about like go for
a hookup right like I'm about to sin
if I said on a show the girls to sleep
on the first date are [__] skanks
they'd call me my hotel and be like oh
we're not sleeping this is our first day
because they they heard it on the show
and I'd be like okay that's not how this
works you gotta leave my hotel right now
but now I know why guys lie because they
go they don't want that where she's like
blue balls them and just cuddles them so
they go hey I don't care about your body
count just take your clothes off and
[__]
but uh if I do any phony [__] I don't
even get hard I don't get aroused I'd be
like I need to be John zurka if I'm
gonna sleep with the girl if I feel like
I'm watered down sir cook I'm an auto
sexual it's weird I know but like I
turned myself on so if it's not Circa in
the room with the girl it's way less
hard for me way less hard if it's circus
saying what up [__]
then I just can be myself and like I
don't feel like the government's gonna
come take take me away I don't know this
is weird well I also think that like
some guys will say they don't care
because in there had women lie anyway so
they'll never know
which I I think is a cope I think like
they'll figure it out eventually to like
that's that's my if they're
but like I think women tend to tell on
themselves in the long run
um I don't think any man can do like a
year and a half of celibacy anymore when
I did that the year flew by so I was
like oh my God I didn't I didn't I
wasn't like you every month I gotta push
harder and it was easy like a year and a
half just flew by and I was just busy in
my work and I read books and I did all
this right
um and then I read even more when I had
a girlfriend because I felt that urge
when the lockdowns were over that you
know I've been cooped up I need to do
some social things because I already
suffered from anti-social personality
disorder it actually damaged my career
because I wouldn't collaborate with
anyone for years just make money alone
so when I got out in the world I'm like
oh I'm about to be a hoe you know
because I'm impatient I'm not gonna like
wait for the right girl so I just picked
my favorite girl who's anti-vaxx and got
banned for that manga and I was like
let's go travel and if I have one
girlfriend
I don't cheat like I know I know who I
am it's very easy for me and so all that
extra energy I just put into books and
stuff but if I had multiple women I
would have never read these books I
wouldn't be in this position in this
hotel none of that and so I played the
game smart like really smart and that's
why that's where Myron and I disagree
the most is like he tells Ben to have
like four girlfriends I think men are
their best that they have one and zeros
how you make a billion dollars but you
know you still need to you don't want to
waste your youth you know you still want
to find the girl right this was an
Einstein a virgin
no he [__] this cousin
Oh I thought I thought there was some
guy that was a famous virgin but I don't
remember I thought it was Einstein you
think you have Nick Fuentes who made a
million dollars and did you still don't
think about women he just wants his
movement to grow and it's such like a
like men don't realize having an army
and being a general is way better than
sex
sex you can have for the rest of your
life like that'll come but uh yeah
actually watching Nick is why I went
sober for like a year and a half
and because I I know that that energy if
you're not dating where does it have to
go you think oh am I gonna die alone no
I'm gonna have an Empire and then women
will want me and I'll be safe from
despair because I can choose pick and
choose and if you build a big enough
Empire you can even have a virgin maybe
you have to go into a Hut like
I actually I almost think that like
the way women are today makes it harder
for virgins too because like how does
the men gonna know if she is
yeah I mean like I've heard guys I've
heard that guy say that like girls will
even lie about that like say they're
virgin
yeah
yeah like girls lie about a lot when it
comes to dating they lie a lot because
the whole the whole world's pointing at
them saying they [__] up and they're
always but uh the interesting thing is
nobody understands that the biggest turn
off for a girl is if you don't know how
to like put a condom on or you're like
sexually inexperienced yeah that
translates to every part of the
relationship so a virgin has a bunch of
trouble unless he knows their nature
like there's only one virgin who gets it
it's Nick he dick has beautiful women
dming him and or they try and get on his
podcast to win and move over like these
neocon type girls and uh he understands
women because he's so intelligent but
nobody has that kids IQ so all these
virgins are kind of [__] you know and
they really need to focus on the Trinity
uh in of dating which is you know their
looks and hygiene their Network the most
important one
and um
no no I actually I know one who I I
believe I like I think she's a virgin
like I believe it I know another girl
that I know a couple girls that waited
till they were married from like my high
school they're very Catholic
um but are they happy yeah I think so
um I haven't talked to them in a bit but
the one like she's um
she's been married for like three four
years now
um she's kid marriage is considered like
some kind of like Lucid topic no that's
the end game of life it's like dude
growing old alone
I hate saying this but your parents
won't be around your siblings will be
with their people you will be alone even
if you have family friends you'll be
you'll have that feeling of alone
sometimes especially if you don't have a
purpose in life but women don't
understand and men that like marriage is
end game it's not career career is the
bridge the marriage marriage is
everything marriage is if marriage
wasn't in the Bible I wouldn't take it
serious but uh yeah when I was like wow
this book actually figured out how
humans have to like coexist but the
marriage is everything you know
uh so tell me about what
all right I'm gonna ask you about this
I'm trying to be respectful so how
Dustin just hit me I'm not I'm not gonna
cry no no not you not you Destiny what
happened weren't you guys friends now
you're not like I just I saw a tweet of
his today
I had a conversation with his wife when
she was at sneakos and I'm like look man
it's been probably like months and
months of me like I've always Juiced
this channel every time he's called me
on I'll go and it's not like I grow with
the liberal audience I go there for like
conversations and it's fun you know it's
good banter but really it's a chore too
right and
really it's like if I leak the DMS
there's 35 Plus DMS where he just leaves
me on red and then when he needs me I
just always go and you know it's been
like this for years but I always I
always thought of it as he's edgy I'm
edgy so I want to be around this guy
Manny does this thing to Nick where like
he just pretends he has a reason that
karamati didn't he just juice Nick and
then Juiced his content with Nick and
then you know he knew exactly when to
exit very political move
and then he pretended like oh there's
like no he's actually a bad guy and
stuff so when he did it to Nick and he
still wouldn't collaborate with Nick
even when I'm talking to Nick it's like
it would have been the greatest collabs
of us all together everyone wants it
wouldn't do it backed out of the debate
with uh me Nick on politically provoked
and
then he just like says something about
circus going through it like he's having
a crackhead moment so I'll come back to
him later I'm like that's not how it
works bro if I leaked these DMs I would
look like the softest sweetest
sweetheart on Earth and I would go with
all the memes of she got you on no
jumper it's not true I just say it
because it's like he would have he's a
nice guy he would have actually got me
that connect so I was like if he would
do it I'll just say he did but really I
had the email months in advance even the
producer of no jumper and stuff were
like no he didn't get you on but uh you
know I would just protect his reputation
and say yo he has great relationships
with women who are trying to kill him
and cancel them you know how would you
protect him from Mr girl everyone who
attacked him and
yeah and then when I saw he did that all
that stuff to Nick and he's doing it to
me still I'm like this is kind of gay
plus he's a red pill Orbiter attacking
my whole movement I'm like this is like
the most one-sided abusive relationship
I've ever been a part of
and I'm not really an Orbiter you know
I'm Circa I'm bigger than him so it's
like dude you know from a business
perspective he looks like a [__] too
so I was like all right and he's always
let his community just like call me her
rapist and weird [__] like that or like
evil [__] but recently I saw all the
commas 72 000 views on a YouTube video
and they're all [__] on me
pretending like he's the good guy in
this friendship
when for years they've been saying
Circle has been so good to you so
loyalty it there's clips of Dustin said
for four years I never had a problem
with Circa uh either we've never had a
problem but I'm I was way too good to
that guy and being around sneak on these
people made me realize like
am I nicer to Steve than snico
and there's something [__] I have like
uh Stockholm syndrome with that [__]
loser so I said [__] it if the whole
chat's gonna [__] on me and he's
promoting it he's not even saying now
circa's a cool dude that guy's a [__]
snake like what the [__] but I don't
want to say snake like I take it
personal if I saw him on the street I'd
say hey but definitely it's like kind of
gay for me to be involved in that kind
of relationship when there's people who
bust ass for me like real friends
and and when you weigh it I've done way
more for that guy than he has done for
me but no one will ever see it because
he's the bigger Channel which is so
stupid because when I'm the bigger
Channel what do you think I'm going to
abandon him how do I help the [__] out
of him just like I shouldn't be fighting
Mr girl from him but I do it anyway so
what's Mr girl I don't actually know
what happened
he's like some pedal that Destiny would
defend in his community and then he
turned on him and tried to make Destiny
uh sexual abuser and I defended him even
though I didn't talk to Stephen for
months
and uh yeah I just instinctively always
defended him and then now it's kind of
like
even if he was in my life
dude there's people like kill Mike and
sneakers who do so much for me that it's
like I wouldn't really waste my time
with Steve and I was offering I was like
Steve I want to come straight drops we
do content and he's always like when I
went through the hill Mike house she
does a [__] hit piece on me it's just
uh you being used by heal Mike and stuff
basically it's like I'm not juicing his
Channel with karantos and all those
other [__] losers he stays with he's
with Humanity but he'll Mike's giving me
a bunch of crypto money and bringing me
the investors and like all this good
stuff so I'm like damn bro this guy's
actually Clueless
but yeah that's the last time I want to
talk about that because uh really
Destiny's not a bad guy he's just a
businessman
but he's a stupid businessman right he's
like literally stupid it's uh I'm
I'm the money
so and then what happened with you were
friends with Abba and preach for a while
or Abba like no I wasn't friends with
them okay they would show up on the
destiny panel where I'd be trolling
Stardust and I guess his feelings got
hurt and then he starts just screaming
at me Circle you'll never be [__] you'll
never be that I'll do a twenty thousand
dollar bet that you won't have a hundred
thousand Subs this year because on
YouTube because you're lazy you're this
and I I offered a different bet that's
more realistic for him I'm like what
about this is easy
and now it's like he's gonna [__]
who's the better sort of probably but uh
basically he's blue pill so Abba hates
Christians on the low I mean this guy
got his uh [__] licked by his woman
woman would preach or whatever and he
said it he said it's not gay and he
knows my position on it so he
immediately hates me because I'm gonna
call it gay and he's like okay I don't
know yeah
and I used to make fun of iron and fresh
all the time not a fan like I roasted
everyone right everyone could get it but
and 2 000 people in my truck were on
Abbas and preacher's side red pill guys
on their side and like don't you see
what's happening here like these are the
bad guys
so I defended them even when I didn't
know them like a year ago there's a clip
on YouTube
but yeah I always I hate blue pill
people like they always eventually snake
you know I actually think Destiny's the
least snake from the blue pill crowd you
know he's like the most watered down if
you have a relationship with them
preach will call you a rapist so if they
call Martin a rapist imagine what they
do to me yeah so yeah well even um
freaking that
I used to like think that like Adam and
preach were right because I thought
Myron looked like insane in that one
video like when he was like we are
better like like I really thought it was
insane like just watching like clips and
everything
um but it wasn't until they started
doing it to me that I realized what they
do where they'll like they'll take a
clip like because there was this podcast
I was like joking about this is before I
actually thought women shouldn't vote so
it's funny because now I actually do
think that but back then I didn't I
swear like you lost like you yeah yeah I
was I was just joking around about it
and they clipped it like I really
thought that we should not vote but you
know I guess maybe they just
foreshadowed it because then I changed
my mind on that later you know you get
more red people and then there was like
I forgot what the next one was but they
would like always clip out all context
um and I just realized like what the
real like all of the reaction channels
do that and then when you point them
like you point to them and you say
you're not providing context then
they'll say oh that's a cop-out but I'm
like no it's actually not
um but yeah that was how I started to
like flip I don't know my opinion on it
because I just started to see what they
were doing when they started doing it to
me
yeah I mean there's a way to roast
channels and be reacting a React channel
with with being charitable at the same
time and those guys are not it dude like
remember they're a lot more red than you
think buying clothes doors but they know
how to play to the audience right they
want everyone to be watching their video
not just like a red side or a blue side
they're businessmen
but it's slimy business you know it's
atheist business right they don't have
like malls yeah I mean Apple even said
in one of the videos that he made it
like
um he made it like a race thing like
when I I sent him a video of me telling
a girl that a 200k ring is delusional
and he's like oh this white girl he's he
was like he was like this white girl's
like clowning black women I'm like what
does that have to do with race like it's
it's a 200k engagement ring that's
insane and I was really nice about it in
the video like if you actually watch the
video it's actually quite Prime yeah no
no it's funny that the audience just
goes with whatever they're saying even
if they don't understand it like that
has nothing to do with race or like for
me it's funny the monkey joke isn't as
funny as my caveman joke because you
look uh preach looks like a man like
Neanderthal and I made a spirit Trucking
joke
they TR they changed it to oh it's a
race joke it's like uh and I made an
evolution joke like from Neanderthal
human and they're like he's saying that
this black man is a monkey
and I'm like you know what's funny I
don't care if you say that bro actually
now that you say that I will say it
but
that is not my joke and but I guess it
looks bad because I'm laughing at Myron
going
it's a giant police officer on live
being racist and [__] or racist you know
making racial comedy
and to me that's just funny
and I never once even did that joke or
like the uh I know they're convinced her
because the type to say hard R but it's
never been a clip of me saying hard
artar ever or anyone who's ever heard me
say it because like I don't like the
gamer
uh comedy but when Myron does it ex
police officer who's black it looks
[__] ridiculous obviously I'm gonna
laugh but man they're UPS I know they
don't think we're racist but they know
what they're doing you know
well unfortunate yeah and even they gave
like
um Myron like they're on me so hard
about saying I would accept like a guy
that cheats and they always misquote
what I say I don't I say if you're
married you got kids like I think you
should try to work it out and I looked
at studies behind like when they
interviewed cheaters and let's just say
the cheaters are lying right 85 percent
of cheaters it's a one-time thing
and let's say the cheaters lost whoa is
that true yeah yeah yeah so it's it's
it's roughly it's breaking imagine
destroying the family unit for a
one-time thing wow thank you thank you
and let's say let's double it know that
let's see let's see let's say I mean
it's self-reported right but let's say
the cheaters are big Liars Circa let's
just say they're the baby come on who's
gonna tell the truth double it okay
that's still the majority it's a one
time I mean how often are men getting
thrown at them let's just be honest for
the average like guy you know so it's
like in my head you know I I don't want
to be cheated on I wish not to be you
know but they'll frame it like I want to
be cheated on I'm like I do not but when
you when you see how much more
anti-social men are than women
women shouldn't really worry about men
cheating they should worry about being
like very [__] and annoying at home
because when men have girlfriends
everyone agrees that we just play
Playstation and go to work we stay home
very loyal if the environment's Cozy no
man goes to the club when they have a
girlfriend they hate we hate clubs when
we have girlfriends all right right
women don't get it the problem is the
environment is so horrible that the man
thinks yeah I'm not going to make it
with this [__] [__] she's so [__]
I need to look for someone else and
that's the problem and you know what's
funny is men don't throw away marriages
for some [__] hoe who's harder than
their wife
invested Bond time energy all this stuff
into the wife
so she the woman's usually safe it's the
woman who will upgrade the woman will
upgrade that's in her DNA well and and
you see it like they don't believe in
marriage like and it's really offensive
to people that believe in me like I I
think I had a debate with um destiny
where I was saying like that you
shouldn't get divorced over chores and
he's like oh what are you acting like a
child right now and I'm like no because
I believe in the sanctity of marriage
and that's the way they'll frame it it's
like they they've completely lost what
marriage is supposed to be and it's
actually it's quite offensive to like
people that are and I'm not even a
die-hard like super super Catholic
person but like I it's kind of offensive
when it's like you're taking a vow with
God and you're getting divorced over a
one-time cheating chores over like
little things that could be little if
you let it be little
yeah it's almost like he watched porn
but you know that's almost the same
thing of what he did is it wasn't that
deep but you know like so I remember my
cousin calling me a fake red pill
because like on camera I could do a lot
of jokes like this but my girlfriend I
would never let her bring uh uh clean my
room or bring me water or like do chores
for me because I can't see a human
slaving away from me I don't know why I
can't I can't see my mom do it for me I
was like stop doing this stop doing me
favors I don't like when humans do that
I feel really cringe when I'm a fresher
fit and the girls bring me stuff because
I just feel like
I don't know I just can't do that you
know and I gotta overcome that and say
[__] do some [__] house work but
really I I want
yeah I've never been that kind of guy
that's like you know I'm red building
everywhere every place but I don't want
her to cook food I want to order food
all I wanted to do is sit in front of a
[__] mirror and be pretty and stay
around me quiet right and it's like
the weird thing is if you're not in the
authority position where you're like
cleaning the house they leave you like
think of it if I got into a woman's car
and I sat in the passenger seat kicked
my feet up and said babe where are you
taking me
dude that is the biggest turn off to a
woman
so it's like we men don't actually real
like we'd love to kick our feet up you
take initiative and drive her to the
restaurant and plan it and all that
because that's what arouses her to you
know keep her around but it's like a lot
of people think men want to be over a
woman no no they have to or they lose
her we'd love to say I'm not working
[__] this [__] you work we'd love to
[__] kick it for a couple months but
we love to work too so we'll go back to
that but it's like I don't teach men to
be the authority in the relationship
because it's like fetish like red pill
guys yeah she's doing what I want no
it's because she's gonna leave you if
you don't right even I think there's a
president who said his game was he makes
his woman doing favors all the time and
she psychically thinks if I'm doing
favors he must be my boyfriend was it
like Edison or someone I forgot what it
was like this quote but it turned out to
be true that the more she's investing in
you the more she'll stick around which
is so weird it's like a woman's like a
golden retriever you know put the [__]
to work
now I've heard that I'm in Psychology
like people that do favors for you like
you more
then like the other way around
but men are like dogs too like if I have
no job I can't really start making out
with her and enjoying her but if I come
home from work then I can because I feel
like a man you know so it's like
yeah we need frisbees we need career
Frisbee and she needs like
an owner
is that gonna hurt your channel no I
don't I don't know I mean at this point
I think it doesn't really
I can't see Chad at all what are they
saying
um he has to be masculine around her
otherwise she'll cheat
um if you look at Circa as pure
entertainment then everything he says
makes sense do you consider yourself
pure entertainment
no actually some guy some idiot at that
meet and greet was pressuring me to say
I know you're not actually like this I
know you're this is just a character and
how much of it is real I said 85.90
and he looked at me like this
like let's go ask my mom it's 80 to 85
to 90 is all real and look at my results
and look at the average man's results
with women I'm dominating
that's what they say to me too they're
like do you actually think these things
I'm like yes I do I mean I'm a woman we
change our mind like the wind you know
what I mean it's like can't can't
promise tomorrow but today I do
but then yeah yeah I even believe you
should start arguments with her
throughout the day for no reason at all
because when you bring a woman toxic
it's controlled and it can be
it can love loud but if you don't bring
her anything and you wait for her to
bring the war he doesn't bring like
bullets she brings nukes like she you
know what I mean
yeah you have to like anytime they'll be
sitting on a couch I'll be like look at
you sitting there [__] loser you got
nothing to do that keeps them around
longer than me being quiet and her
coming to me I feel like a loser I don't
do anything when I date you so you have
to like hot and cold actually stimulate
them you do anything to a woman just
don't or her
if she loves you she [__] you if she
hates you she [__] you more
but if she's bored of you indifferent
you've lost her right I've gone into so
many parties where girls like you're the
sexist guy aren't you on Twitch you're
the sexiest guy and all the guys are
like zirko's not getting any and because
of that polarizing energy they all
surround me trying to debate me and now
I can pick and choose which one I want
but if I enter the room as an average
Joe
they're indifferent to me and they don't
know I'm in the room another thing if
you know this is how you can tell if
women respect you when you enter a room
do they sit up straight or do they
Flinch they're not like oh circus gonna
knock me out right but like women
actually change immediately their
posture they touch their hair they play
right as soon as you walk in a room but
if you're a nobody they're looking at
their phone they look at you and oh
Tom's here you know they don't do
anything so do you you'll know you're
polarizing with the way uh the energy
shifts when you enter do you think that
it's in in a like eventually she's gonna
get bored like I mean if you if you're
married for say 50 years you don't think
at some point she's gonna get bored
well I mean ending ending that Unity
that cannot be replaced no even if you
have a new one it's just not replaced it
can never be replaced just because
you're bored
kind of shows that like the woman's
suffering from autism or something
because
that's why you have to give them kids
right if
a woman is either prepping you as the
father of her kids or she's leaving you
she's either going in one trajectory or
the other and uh they don't get bored
with kids you give them kids and they'll
be fine are you be surprised you know I
always say I'm going to be so charitable
because it's your show less memes here I
always say single husbands do better
than single moms but a woman in a happy
marriage is such a better motor than the
father even if the father tries his best
he can he can't compete even 25 so when
women are happy that's the one time they
can actually function at a black belt
level and beat a man at something right
like if you see a healthy Muslim family
or Christian family the mom is way way
more important than the dad raising the
kids and the dad's kind of like
impactful in it for their sons and
daughters ideology but really the mom's
like doing all the work you know when I
think of my mom compared to my dad it's
like my mom was the greatest Mom on
Earth yeah I've never heard my mom say
one cuss word like I've never heard her
say the f word or anything so when I
meet women I'm always depressed because
uh like I get women to say slurs around
me so it's like we
so it's fun but it is weird that I grew
up with the archetype of the first woman
that I saw in my when I came out the
birth canal never like she's the highest
level of Purity I've ever seen in a soul
so every woman even the pure ones today
look very dirty to me right where it's
like yeah just like you know women swear
and you know they act like men now do
you want to get married
yeah I've been saying this for the
longest time it's like marriage is like
the biggest thing
is bigger than kids for me you know I
don't really fantasize about kids I know
I'm supposed to have them but I
fantasize about marriage way more like
because I've always been I had two
relationships and loyal and both of them
well they said like I'm verbally abusive
I'm the worst guy I'm Satan I'm evil but
they said the one thing he's good at is
he's loyal and it's like dude there's
this confidence I was trying to tell
Myron this the other day there's this
confidence a man gets when all the sins
of the world are like at your fingertips
and you say no for your wife
but
I can see that marriage flopping like
even billionaires like Trump have three
marriages like you just I can see it
flopping and that's that's why I'm
thinking I'm just gonna marry a retired
hole like Trump
I'm just gonna do that
why
because if I get a pure one she won't be
as attractive as the ones that I'm used
to
because if you're attractive the world
gets to you first the notifications and
the whole world DMS you first so
kind of [__]
and and all your beauty the most because
uh for some reason when the girl's
beautiful she could throw a frying pan
at me like they try to stab me with
knives and I'm kind of smiling it's not
that bad you know when they're beautiful
when they go crazy it's not that bad for
me but if they're mid and they go crazy
then I go like holy [__] maybe I want to
transition and beat her up you know
once she be mid in 10 years anyway
no
15 no no no
oh her yeah like if she well you know if
you get an attractive woman they
actually level out if you get a mid they
go under they go up but if you like
oh I was just thinking like wouldn't she
be mid later anyway like I'd imagine by
like 45 like most women are mad
and you're gonna live to be like what 90
80. most people 80 75.
me I I I'm the average person like 75 I
don't know your health no like I'm
already over I've already overdosed
twice and had some organ issues so I I
don't think I'm going to 40. oh okay
yeah then you might as well value also
I'm tall tall people don't tall men
don't go that far
I'm tall too is that is that bad
for women have you ever how tall are you
okay guess yes
511 is tall yeah I'm six foot
six foot have you ever seen a granny
who's six feet tall
you're [__] you're so [__]
may I pee
yeah go ahead
no I'm kidding I didn't raise my hand
okay I'm gonna pee and how am I doing is
this 100 because I've mastered the
people I like I give them better shows
than the people I don't like
this is good no you're good there's like
2 500 people in the chat
go okay
okay guys let me if you have any
questions for him super Chatham
um
am I gonna die young
so that yeah he's going to the bathroom
so
Pearl just hunch over to be shorter what
do that nope I have not you nobody's
seen a six foot granny
put a one in the chat one in the chat if
you've seen a six foot six foot granny
nobody
nobody there's 2 400 people in here
guys I'm nervous to ask him I wanted to
ask more about the Freemason stuff but I
don't want to get banned off of YouTube
the Freemason I can't go into right
I can
you sure won't ban me
off of YouTube
yeah
all right I'm gonna do it but if I get
banned
I don't do it
oh viewer activity okay
oh I see blessing is all right
blessing is top producer go Pearl Circa
has good game and advice but he thinks
being big gives him the right to lower
the entire room's IQ no skills but
besides imitating I don't even know who
Joey Diaz is shout out to Pearl and
Circa we need to re raise real Alphas
they say you won't get banned
um
you'll put a Target on your back
Freemason literature ask him about his
tattoo though
maybe you're back
do you have a I do have a rumble I do
guys if you have any questions for him
put him in the chat
also also uh like the video we have over
2 000 people in here so there should be
there there should be over 2 000 likes
guys a like is free
like oh my grandma was over six foot and
she lived into her 80s
you know my grandma was she was like 70
she just died she's like 75.
Flat Earth Freemason
so you guys do think he's a Fed huh
what about the minimum what's the
ask him about his book list and what
banned books he reads and recommends
everyone wants me to ask everyone else
I'm not talking about that what
I'm not talking about banned books
illegal books what the [__] oh okay I I
wanted to ask you more about the
Freemason stuff but I was afraid that
would nuke my channel
no it won't I won't okay everyone does
that for clickbait you're safe with that
word okay John uh I'm gonna I'm gonna do
one super chatted question and then I'm
gonna ask you about it
um John how would you instruct your
future daughter to deal with men and
your son to deal with women
um
for my daughter I would say I choose but
I'll give her like 30 men to pick from
I'll give her a big quantity of men so
she doesn't feel like oh he [__] me
over
and um and I would want to get her I
would want her to get it
like a extremely Catholic Family I want
them to marry for her to marry into that
um
and for the Sun
I would say you're not getting married
till you're
33 like 34. like you're you're making
millions first
would you tell him to to sleep with a
lot of girls would you tell them to like
have a girlfriend how would you tell him
to do it
no I would tell him you can have a
girlfriend if it means it's like how I
did it to Nick gate sleeping around
but if he's gonna have a girlfriend and
a loser and then sleep around and do all
of it [__] no right but he can have a
girlfriend that's like
she she fits the boxes of marriage but
there's no pressure for marriage she
normally she it you know just
honestly really I I would clown him if
he had a girlfriend if he's 21 22 23
with a girlfriend
he's not gonna make he's not gonna be a
success story at all
uh Navi says two questions for circa on
page 17 of morals and Dogma Pike speaks
about entering the lodge between two
columns could he be talking about being
birthed also what is the most effective
way to pray
[Music]
um yeah actually in that same book for
effective way to right it's a
reoccurring prayer that's thought words
and even spell cast where you write it
or not in like a satanic way uh the
prayer has to reoccur throughout your
life so let's say you prayed for our
certain career path
you actually have to do the work I think
Carl Jung has a quote where it's like if
you do your work conscientiously
and in good spirit friends come and find
you so I've been doing the work on
Twitch on content and now people are
reaching out hey come on my shows and
stuff like that that's how it works but
the prayer cannot just be I want this
career and then you go back to thinking
of all the degenerate [__] the prayer
has to consume you like the MMA fighter
the boxer martial artist or anyone who's
been obsessed with their activity it has
to consume your mental plane if it's a
prayer like you her career like
something you want and I think every
prayer should be first negated with
praying for your family to be healthy
and then what you want because if you'd
say what you want before that prayer you
might get it that's not something you
want so I've never had a prayer where I
say this is I always say to God the
prayer is not actually what I want I
want my family healthy
but
I'm working on this and if if I can get
a boost
so and another thing would be uh the
parent would have to be in your most
wakeful state and your sleepiest day so
your solar and leaner psyches
what's the other question oh page 17
um talks about the pillars right Joaquin
and Boaz yeah those pillars talk about
the birth canal not really it's just
Beauty and uh strength right and uh
when you look at it this is what's so
interesting about psychologist do you
know are you familiar with Carl Jung bro
I've heard of him but I don't I don't
remember I don't remember much about him
so one of the biggest breakthroughs he's
had that made him the greatest of all
time he said that there's 12 archetypes
that the human uh has in his psyche and
he can work to enter into another kind
of state so there's be there'd be like
The Man Child who's like a good life but
you know it doesn't get where he wants
there's the old man there's Architects
we just know we just know
and really this amount of study
witchcraft with uh serpent worshipers in
Africa before he popped off an occult
scientist and he wrote the red book and
the five black books and all this spell
casting and all the a lot of demonic
[__] and he sells the soul in one of the
books to Magic but he doesn't know what
magic is he just knows it's tempting and
yeah yeah anyways so this Carl young guy
those 12 archetypes he talks about that
Jordan Peterson rehashed and stuff like
that
they were there before Carl Young
discovered it they're the zodiacs
those pagan gods they used to worship of
Mars Jupiter of virtue
those archetypes ancients understood
that's what's so creepy about when you
look into psychology and science it's
always aligns either with mysticism or
the Bible
and that's
literally shocking that Carl Young is
late to understanding that and he was
the first to break to have that
breakthrough of the archetypes right all
right call him is my favorite
psychologist what do you mean 12 like
the 12 Architects are those for men and
women or just men
and women yeah okay so like what's your
archetype
okay are these real or like it's it's
like a demon thing it's like bad
no they're real they're they're real
like you can actually do things like
once you understand Carl Young well you
can understand which archetype is you're
you've entered that's making you your
life miserable and I'm the warrior
okay
what's what's my archetype do I get one
I don't know no you have to really
really do there's a lot of tests you can
do online you go to really answer some
deep questions before you can pinpoint
yourself because they overlap no you
can't be 100 of one architect
uh does that make sense yeah kind of
like you you'll talk about some stuff
and I'm like I don't know if I fully
understand what you're talking about
it's weird if I have the notes on me I'm
way better at it but I'm terrified of
going off the top of my head in case I
embarrass myself so I'm like just keep
it simple here but if if I'm at my PC I
could break it down on Ms paint
completely
but basically you're saying that there's
12 Architects that the psychologist came
up with right and it oh no no no no no
no no wait wait sorry that he discovered
observed okay yes but they but they um
okay that he observed and yeah but the
people like a long time ago also
understood them and these are the zodiac
signs and it's aligned with the planets
yes because remember
Carl Young said every Star is an angel
and every space a start does not inhabit
is like a demon devil right and you
gotta look at star Trails they all go
into they all follow God's path except
the ones that fell from Grace the Fallen
Angels they have their own paths so Mars
the god of war and stuff like that and
we have those traits in Kabbalah and
mysticism we all have those seven
Revelations seven against seven traits
and 12 archetypes for the Zodiac we have
these in us but each one comes with a
good and a bad and apparently they can
Team us and they perfectly align with
greed and be lust and everything in the
Bible
it's all it's all my documentary and it
makes so much more sense when I have
visuals like I'm about to blow up the
internet without a documentary oh I was
like oh I wanted to know where I could
watch it it's not done something crazy
my twin brother who has a master's
degree for psychology
uh he's a therapist this is how he
listens to me he's like you know more
about Carl Jung and Floyd than me
because because he's not spiritual so
the stuff it kind of becomes foggy too
but when you're spiritual right when you
believe in God 100 this stuff becomes
like I need to know it you know and uh
and he put me on really right like when
or Troy when Freud said
Marines are uh just wish fulfillment so
if you're having nightmares you're
wishing the worst upon yourself and how
about nightmares of people coming to try
and kill stop and rape me and [__]
at the peak of when I hated myself which
I still hate myself to this day and I
rarely dream but when I do it's the same
kind of stuff
but Boyd is so is credited and these
guys are like not good human beings but
they said a lot of Truth
he's discredited by feminists and this
describes the father of psychology like
Roy will change your life if you read
Floyd it's Insanity work but he is
different from Young where he thinks
everything's psychosexual whatever
happens to you as a child and stuff like
that everything has to do with sex which
is funny because the gn3 masonry is not
for grand architect it's actually
regenerative principle
which is sex and so everything is sex
that's why engineers build Bridges like
everything in the world revolves around
that astral flame that makes you want to
have that the right kind of orgasm and
the family and all that but uh you see
someone who's a virgin like Nick
do you know how much electricity is
buzzing in that kid she could take over
the world as a virgin that's how
powerful that uh Purity regeneration
type of uh lifestyle is and uh yeah
there's there's this thing about men
being pure into adulthood that makes
them Geniuses actually
what is Freemason I don't understand is
that connected to this or is that
different
Freemasonry is like an open Society
right open Society but the it's veiled
in secrecy and they only reveal the
truth to the higher ranking ones but
really it's a Protestant arm of the
Jesuit liberal order of the Vatican and
it comes from Jewish mysticism in
Kabbalah
stuff like that and um
it pretty much reverse Engineers the
Bibles these rituals its hosts and uh it
encompasses all ancient religions of
antiquity all Pagan star systems uh star
of Rim Femme molok and everything they
pray to
and uh I really have to it boils down to
Osiris right they're obsessed with each
ship and that's why they wear an apron
to hide the generative principle the
penis right
talks about
okay so it's essentially it's a it's a
secret
Society
with Elise Society they're down the
street but the movers and shakers like
Shaq is a Freemason he's on TV with the
rinky thousands of Freemason they will
connect you to unhappy Pelosi's husband
and teach you where the best
like that if you're a part of the
billionaire ruling class of masonry if
you're just a large Mason it's a little
different where most Freemasons I'd say
like 90 they're just kind of in a club
they don't they don't know what the [__]
they're doing
I feel like if there is this Society
like people would know more about it
like I like I just have a hard time
thinking like videos wouldn't get leaked
and like it would be on the front pages
of stuff
well no it's not a secret every single
president admits that most of them admit
that they go to that Temple they don't
go to church they go to a freemasonic
lodge right it's open they admit this
who like Trump
uh Google every president who was a
Freemason openly that talked about it
there's a huge list no way huh
even Trump when you look at millionaires
they look at analytics and statistics
there's a picture of trump pointing to a
cabal his Kabbalah teacher you know
kabbalah teacher which is Magic
why do billionaires have magic teachers
it's because they spell cats like
McDonald's has a red and yellow
uh logo to stimulate appetite to sell
more right that's a psychic programming
uh they wouldn't use blue and all
marketing at the billionaire class
actually comes from religion like what
is 7UP it's pointing at the seven
planets of antiquity that they worship
um even Nike is the Saturn string the
logo right the cabalists worship Saturn
the furthest from the sun because
there's only seven apartments in this
version
oh yeah
what do you think it was push you
thought it was just a check I don't know
or look at Marina Marina Abramovich she
got a billionaire uh Bill Gates to
sponsor her and Jay-Z and all these guys
and all she does is blood spirit cooking
art
but they're not the billionaires don't
do art for art
right they're actually communicating
with uh spirit world that's why uh
Hitler's School Society was started by
Wizards uh you this is all open you can
Google it
um and these people are obsessed with
real energy from the eat they're upset
and and communicating channeling with
demons and a lot of freemasonic monitors
that they talk about
if you've never painted a painting in
your life you can enter a psychic
translate causing a Consciousness State
uh hallucin where you kind of
hallucinate and you can do a Mona Lisa
but really you're channeling demons and
they always take over at the end and a
lot of people pop off when you look at
Madonna and a lot of these Stars they're
always doing some kind of magic what do
you mean magic I have I have do you know
people people on Brad Pitt's level like
these kind of games I linked over 98 uh
no
96 celebrities at Brad Pitt status and
money level
just in Hollywood not even politicians
I've linked them all to Freemasonry
Kabbalah Blackmagic there's white magic
green magic and black magic right but
I've linked all of them and you can even
see the Ukrainian soldiers in Ukraine
there you if you YouTube they do this
ritual where with Earth fire air and
water this is how they do it even Saudi
Black magicians do this worldwide they
all do this
it is Ukrainian soldiers cut bleed into
the dirt and light a fire in the dirt
and pray to this big [__] wooden
Pagan God and it's another but if but if
Christ is like the God is stronger than
the devil like why would they pray to
the devil
well it's only for the material world
it's not for Infinity like this is a
this is this material world is just a
blink Infinity is everything so if you
think about it they're only getting fun
in the material world and it's not
regular fun these people are using their
minds they're going through psychosis if
you look at how much success
schizophrenics have had with exorcists
compared to a big Pharma it's insane
when you look at both studies
uh yeah these people believe that our
fentanyl a fentanyl addict has a dead
fentanyl someone who died from fentanyl
their security inhabits someone else and
that's where they get the impulses the
invisible impulses that criss-croft and
it's like you can make them do more
drugs they don't want to do the drugs
but they need the drugs and yeah that's
all in their documentary actually so I'm
way deeper than Alex Jones let's go like
the video
um are you supposed to be somewhere
right now that chat is
party I didn't think would be an hour
late to start but it's already done that
I know I've done that YouTube channel
and I don't want to thank you for not
coming to Chicago so you're more
important
for Chicago again okay
um
don't worry okay they're they're putting
it in the chat calling the queen
um wow but that's so interesting huh and
this this is like YouTube friendly they
let you talk about this on here
oh yeah all this is YouTube friendly
there's people who make a lot of money
talking about this stuff but it's very
low level shallow they talk about
Raptors and [__]
uh they want to know what the biggest
girl you've ever been with is
any hope
every girl I've been with is the same
frame as my ex like because I kind of
get the same body type every time
is there any hope for chubby girls in
obtaining high value men
maybe but not me
[Laughter]
um if you could snap your fingers to fix
the modern dating scene what would it be
Catholic theocracy
I want and I don't really believe a
woman has to marry an older man I
believe men can be men at 16. they could
go to war on 16 they used to do it for
thousands of years so a 16 year old
woman or a 16 year old girl whatever
would marry a 16 year old boy in my
perfect system and and he wouldn't be
immature he would be you'd be prepared
and he'd be pure and he'd be like
Knights Knights used to not even tell
White Lies that's how religious they
were
yeah they were trying to say that was
bad but you said the 16 year olds
marrying each other but it's like what
good what good does it do they're
thinking I'm [__] a 16 year old
that's why they call me a pedal they're
like he wants it for himself and I'm
like there's most people in my movement
would want an older guy with a 16 year
old I'm not gonna lie but I think
and you can mature if you're in the born
in the right environment you can mature
at 16 and so boy you could be a hunter
at 16 easily
and you have a piece of energy and
puberty right there
um I don't know who Dawson is but
someone said have you heard from Dawson
lately
oh wait that was the guy in the other
stream right oh right that was that was
the one you that didn't that made you
get kicked
yeah have you talked to him since
no but uh people are saying I should
stop talking [__] about him because
apparently his documentary is made for
me like I'm gonna love it so when I give
it a chance I don't want to have bitter
feelings I just want to enjoy it
uh what is oh yeah why are you going at
the Tates
uh I I did I said I'm having a cold time
to think I do a lot of bait me
meme like tweets and uh it's great
marketing but uh his brother messaged me
he's like I I talked to my brother and
he has nothing scheduled you dork and
I'm like dude I got canceled defended
these guys when I didn't even know if
they were human traffickers I just went
off the content of their character that
they're not I defended the [__] out of
these guys I'll protect them my family
loves them no my brother and me so it
really stung and I'm not the type of guy
who goes they don't know who I am
because
they're very tapped in they watch
everyone on the internet like they're as
paranoid as me so I'm like no they're
they're really just taking a jab because
I went on a fresh bid and they're like
oh this guy's gonna affect their bottom
line maybe he'll take 10 of our money
and I'm taking all of it [__]
plus I don't really want to have thio
allies
that's all I'm gonna say what's what's
Saito allies what's that
what
Zio allies what is the Zio what's a Zio
Ally
um protecting your channel what the [__]
oh oh you think they're okay I'm gonna
just go on to the next one
um he sold himself to something only if
you will understand it's not Satan some
have realized that um this guy is smart
looking his eyes dbf
um
I I think they're calling you smart
I don't know what is what is your next
uh move with podcast uh content
I just see what my team sends me they
just send me addresses and locations and
times and I do it but really um the only
time I change my schedule is if I know
someone like you or if I snake You by
not coming to Chicago but uh yeah I just
go off with what they do because if I do
the back ends and stuff I quit like I've
quit the every time I got relevant on
the internet I quit but just like did my
own thing and I was dealing with a lot
of personal stuff there and now I really
can't quit because uh I'm not 80 with
God I'm like 100 on board now and so
yeah I feel great but I don't really
know what's next I just know there's
I don't want to leak it should I leak it
if you want
the grilling girl wants me on
oh oh you would be amazing on there
no I know they're okay they won't I I
know I know um standout TV they're not
like I've been on there before not with
her but like with the guy version of
that
they're not
like they don't care so I know I know my
community is going to say clear your
schedule for that one they want that
yeah they'll come to London I'll put you
on shows for like a week
oh hell yeah I'll stay two weeks then if
I get work yeah I don't want to build no
I want to do others I can I can you we
have a whole streaming room too like I
can let you stream too
I can make a dollar it looks full yeah
yeah that's what I I was like I wish um
I wish you were closer I'd help you with
a lot of the the stuff you're because
you're talking about needing an editor
and stuff I'm like I have basically
everything you need
yeah yeah no I have a bunch of people
who help me it's just I don't get on
calls like I save all my energy for a
stream and then I spent four or five
hours alone in dark I don't talk to
anyone I don't do anything and then I
sleep so that's my whole problem is like
I don't want to communicate with my team
I don't want to be a business you know
which is kind of tragic I could have
made fifty thousand dollars Justine told
me this week if I just
but whatever I just focusing I want my I
just want the relevancy and then my
documentary that's it have you ever
attended a traditional Latin Mass
um
no not a traditional one I went to my
first uh Sunday mass last week and then
uh and today I was hurting bad so I went
to church
this is the second time and feels great
I mean I don't belong there I'm not
gonna lie there's a lot of Shame like
I'd be looking I don't make eye contact
with people in church because I feel
like you know it's circles in church you
know and it's weird like I take my hat
off because it's disrespectful but I
don't want people to see me in there you
know I get really ashamed why Catholics
are nice
no it's my past is very sinful and how I
live right now is not that great I mean
it's way a thousand times better than my
past but it's yeah yeah but have you
ever gone to confession
no oh my gosh you should
why you don't
no I'm gonna I'm gonna be baptized this
year 2020
. okay you've never you didn't get
baptized in like a different
day
I've never done anything I've never done
anything religious my whole life
[Music]
um yeah I went to a Protestant Church
once and they just made me play
basketball and I'm like this is not for
me bro oh yeah Protestants it's really
interesting because Protestant like the
way a lot of non-denominational churches
communicate it's very similar to
feminists I can't unsee it I argue with
them on Twitter all the time
like like the way they like weaponize
being a non-believer if you have any
criticism of them it's very it's very
similar to the way like feminist
weaponized sexism
yeah yeah
well I would say 90 of churches pastors
and Priests are compromised I don't like
to say that
but uh
yeah it's become a lot more of a liberal
World well they don't ever preach
against female sin they only preach
against male sin it's like it's really
weird once you see this you can't unsee
it it's like I mean maybe you're pretty
like tuned in
I mean when a woman sins it's the fault
of the man who know the community you
know women can only be bad because Men
Let Them women by Nature aren't that bad
um but when men are just like leaving
them alone and letting them vote can be
equal that's when they go whoa you
abandoned me now you end in my chaotic
nature how could you and then they
rebelled right but really women act very
good in that
spiritual Society they aren't very naps
why do you think the women are so bad in
the church because the men don't hold
them accountable or what
Oh you mean like Catholic school girls
who are all [__]
[Music]
um I think that I mean I just sorry go
ahead
MTP which is based on a television from
a masonic temple I think it's stronger
than the church to these women right
because uh you know they they they're
growing up in a world where they feel
like men are just gonna cheat and leave
them so
they just lose their minds and uh start
becoming hoes
like I feel bad that women have to date
these kind of guys
like you know how many women you know
I've had shy girls and crazy girls say
the same thing I said I'd rather have a
guy who beats me than a sin
when they were done their same face they
start to hate the sins right
like they're wasting their youth on
but like I always say to a girl why you
should be extra feminine around me is
because you're getting the most
masculine channel on the internet in
your bedroom
playing video games with you and
chilling with you you must be so aroused
and I'm getting 50 percent
feminine no if I'm a cartoon you're
gonna be a cartoon what the [__]
but I'm also a hypocrite because you
know people know what I date I date
crazy [__] so they're like Circa are
you sure I I feel like you you get bored
with a feminine girl because you're
always dating crazies and you know
that's actually what a lot of guys like
me have trouble with is like I feel like
I deserve that people learn a lot more
like if I'm around a pure girl I go
sure goes uh holy [__] is God's Gonna
punishment because she's wasting it she
should be with some engineer who's kind
and [__]
so I'd stick to the crazy one who's like
pulling a knife on me and I got a
[__] [__] you know you've had you've
had someone pull a knife on you
yeah most girls are dated I the city
would be afraid to date them they're
cute but like nobody would [__] with
them so I would see it like is a
challenge and I'd be like that's the
ones I deserve
and uh yeah my brother's like dude you
always choose the crazy because if I
pick a pretty girl in my town but she's
not crazy
everyone dated her and [__] her like
that's horrible but the crazy one
everyone will do no don't DM her bro
she's crazy she's gonna [__] ruin
your life she'll put you in prison and I
go yeah but she's 45 to 75 more pure
than the normal one because that [__]
is in therapy you know I read
no
it's a crazy one to have less Partners
they have a lot of life problems okay so
you prefer The Crazy Ones because they
have a lower body count no no it's bad
advice this is not advice when I say my
sins and flaws yeah I'm doing it to be
translated you're advising I'm just
repeating what you said so that's what
you do
yeah
[Laughter]
that's what I've done up until now now
I'm very very single
um they want to know if hypnotism and
freemason's tree is linked
yeah it's very linked actually that's
also in my documentary and
uh hypnotism is real and when you look
into it that's when you immediately get
obsessed with magic and a cult because
you oh [__] this stuff is real
really so there's hypnotists who could
do this and you go like this
um and they can program you it's crazy
and if the hypnotist knows you if the
hypnotist knows your traumas they can
get you in a deeper spell actually
uh Carl Jung there's an interview where
he says he worked with schizophrenics
this kind of she practiced dark arts
right
one of his and I'm pretty sure he was
pushing them to the brink of suicide he
one of his clients blew their heads off
and all he could think about with a
smile on his face was I wanted to see
Carl Gustav young wanted to see if he
was smiling when he pulled it and she
wasn't
so what he saw he regretted when he
killed himself I'm like what the [__]
this guy is like and he had paranormal
Witchcraft and all that stuff happened
to him at a young age like a table
snapped in half and his mother was like
a huge Christian going like we're
haunted so when you read up on his life
that she goes deep quick which is kind
of weird that the deepest part of
conspiracy is like Harry Potter like
that's kind of gay but no it's way
deeper than that because all that
psychic kind of spells and programming
is done through rape rituals it's in my
documentary
who made Harry Potter
it's not a good book it's on the
algorithm for a reason it's not made for
profit it's a top-down control system
they push Harry Potter and our kids and
stuff to normalize it like oh it's just
jokes and stuff no it's real actually in
many people talks about
some Wizards are so strong some of these
gnostics they can shoot array from the
other side of the earth into your mantle
to kill you
why would a genius write that in a book
and he says in the book this is not a
joke
wow
um hello sorry sorry wait so I did in
college they had like a hypnotist come
on stage and I got I got put on the
stage but I just didn't like nothing
happened
they sent me back they said I know they
sent me back because I was just like
okay okay how would you fare if you were
there with a Billionaire's hypnotist
I don't know or even agitate Andrew Tate
has one in the War Room the highest
ranking is a hypnotist
uh so you you probably had a low level
one I mean probably it was like a small
school in Ohio like
Bill Gates brought a hypnotist you'd be
[__]
uh-huh
I don't know this is so conspiracy like
I don't know
um they want to know what you think of
Orthodox Christianity
I don't like it I don't like it they
don't even believe in original sin and I
don't like Protestant and Orthodox I
know I'm supposed to form the chat and
be a businessman and right wing and no
no you guys will convert to Kath
is it Earth
yo let me do the energy fate answer if
he was a Christian yeah they're all good
bro Obama program give me a break
yeah but Andrew you don't think it's
like war room stuff is good
like I mean it like I feel like
everything Pearl Pearl
you are considered a thousand times more
based on the internet because of the top
the J topic that you do in Rumble
with Nick like dude you're considered
more deep than Andrew like that's how
low level he is
give me a break dude
he's never talked about Jay's once which
is so interesting well he said one thing
he said Kanye is doing interesting
things Chad and the chat said oh yeah
pubg and I'm like what the [__] this is
our truther do you believe in aliens of
course
no no
oh because you think the Earth is flat
so there's no solar system also that's
that's why there's billions of dollars
for those kind of shows like ancient
Hills but aliens is like dinosaurs this
attack on the Bible to make you feel
like genesis is not real
it's a spell
but then what what are stars if the
Earth yeah and backwards yeah alien
backwards is Neil Armstrong Neil a like
it's a [__] meme bro what are stars
if the Earth is flat
and the moon oh they're Angels oh
they're Angels they say Stars yeah you
believe they're burning balls of CGI gas
right
I do you know have you ever seen you
know as an adult you've never actually
seen a star through a high-powered lens
do you know what they actually look like
up close
you should look at it it's like almost
like electric energy almost Angelic but
with like uh the waters above kind of
Rippling off it but that'll be in my
documentary too and it's also in my flat
Earth debate with Destiny and yeah what
books do you recommend
thank you
the sort of the Bible that's like 42
books in one though but uh
um
if you're having trouble the Bible just
go to the Jesus Parts I think that's way
better you should start like that
yeah the red text and uh books that I
recommend
I don't read books dude I only read uh
Freemason stuff because uh like if
they're written by an authority or
Freemason or someone who was at the top
of society or I would never read like
The Art of War or anything that's
mainstream like I will never read a book
unless it's from a billionaire or
someone who's like iconic I'll only read
books from the highest levels of power I
will never actually read an author's
book really but if I had to
yeah it's just stupid like how many
people read The Art of War and they're
still broke and losers
but I would stick with Plato I like
Freud I like Carl Young
um schopenhauer
Thomas Sowell is I just thought his
stuff was really interesting like his
history stuff you wouldn't read him
yeah I'll get around to it maybe
I like Donald for more modern books
Donald Trump's mentors book The Power of
Positive Thinking I think is called
balance of your book and Manny P hall
that's and uh
I wrote on my Twitter a book list like
go find it in a comment I reply to some
um and they want to know why do you
defile so many [__] Latinas
what does defile mean
like what are the file like I disparaged
them on Twitter or like date them I
don't know
oh oh I don't know I just have a history
with those that group of people
yeah
yeah no problem
okay I think
that's all my questions that they they
have for you in the chat
you've kind of stumped me I'm not even
gonna lie like you're kind of making my
head hurt with all these Concepts
it's because I'm a genius bro
like think about it a man who didn't
read one book and failed and dropped out
of college and
read his first book at 27 and binged a
hundred books and now they're pouring
through me and
no one reads books so I have a monopoly
in Wisconsin
and if they do they're not entertaining
enough to actually explain the book
it's perfect I want the most
entertaining
truther in the game
and uh I think I [__] killed this
interview I think I did a 10 out of 10.
and you owe me some money
um you know let's not go that far you
know okay well you you know
We're Dreaming in London when I pop off
off the grilling yeah we have like um
three different sets so we have a lot of
we're gonna and we're gonna sign Talent
Talent soon in London so we'll probably
have a ton of people you want to collab
with or anything we're trying to sign
we're gonna we're gonna get we're gonna
get rich together Pro because remember
my whole goal is to not get banned off
YouTube so I'm always going to be able
to collab collaborate with you and then
I'll have deeper stuff in my like
rumbles and kicks and stuff like that
but no you're always gonna see me on
YouTube you're always going to collab
and it's always going to be like like
let's be honest my competition is Logan
Paul
you know how much money I'm Gonna Make
You should definitely like you should
start by signing me to a zero contract
no contract just give me a hundred
thousand dollars you're rich right
Rich right
your podcast made you rich
uh no I don't have as much cash as
people think I reinvested it a lot into
like people equipment and systems so
yeah most of my money honestly I spent
over a hundred grand on equipment
and like because I like it yeah I look
at um I really I mean you wouldn't be
able to tell right now because I'm in
Chicago but I really look at like
um YouTube is Art like I just have a
different view on it like it's
interesting because I get called a
grifter so much but like I just look at
like I think certain content is
literally beautiful like I think when I
put that tape panel together with Renner
I think that was like one of my best
ideas was to put Andrew Tate Brittany
Runner and the two craziest [__] from
my show all on one panel with me and
Auntie Jenny like I just thought that
was a beautiful piece of content
um so it feels like a comic book when
you have a good panel to me it's like
like family like I love it if I had a
Ferrari I wouldn't touch it because I
was busy being like I have the influence
now I can get anyone let's take the
perfect comic book with Nick just need
this guy Logan Paul and yeah I see it as
R2 yeah well and it's actually that's
the only thing the only thing I was ever
good at in school they put me in the
genius accelerated program IEP but only
for they broke the rules you're supposed
to go into all the courses and I was
failing regular
and the teacher is like yeah put them in
the genius program just for art and uh
yeah it's like always into art you know
and and poetry the only classes I ever
got days in is poetry
and art npe well and it's also like
I don't know like I think that like
certain content is like time like we're
talking about this a little bit before
it's like Timeless and I think like I
love it when I can put a conversation on
screen that like reflects Society
so even even like with me like with um
one of my first videos that went viral
which was me red pilling my friend it
was like me like showing basically this
girl that's like 30 you know this is
like we've been taught all wrong and
it's like you see us like slowly like
all of everything that we thought like
going away you know what I mean so it's
like kind of us getting like
I'm gonna react to that on my kids yeah
you should it's um like I red pilled my
friend for the first time
um and that's what I really like about
content is like it really can change
like I didn't even notice that it's so
funny now to like look back but I didn't
even notice we really live in like a
society that discriminates against men
it's not women at all
um and the only the only place women
have been unfair I think is
well I don't want to go this far but if
there's a cool one who's like on our
side or just open to free speech like
you if you're a woman you just get
[__] on you know what I mean just for
being a woman and it's like dude Pearl's
not a feminist like this is not the one
you [__] on what the [__] well and I I
do understand a bit of their criticism
um sometimes because it's like I didn't
realize like if you went to college you
really lived your life like a feminist
as a woman and I never like thought you
know I was already graduated when I
found this stuff but like that's the
that's the biggest like dip in like
fertility rates is actually like I used
to think it was um like birth control
but I actually don't think it was birth
control because birth rates started
declining in the 20s not the 60s and um
that was when women started to live
outside of their parents house like
there would be a gap like they would get
an apartment and then get married and so
like you kind of you kind of understand
their criticism in a way because like if
you went to college you lived your life
like a feminist as a woman
we weren't thinking that at the time I
was just trying to play volleyball
no it's like they're getting educated
but it's not like they're being
millionaires from college they're like
still in debt so it's not really
education like what are they doing yeah
I mean even this content stuff like
everything I learned like I just taught
myself it wasn't like
foreign
ERS will tell you it's it's a
self-learned skill set that made them a
millionaire it's usually not the work
ethic you know I guess comes from
grinding your house in college but I
really in the digital age going to
college is [__] it's like that's
stupid that's what that's what my dad
said too my dad
um he was really smart he went to the
University of Chicago and he dropped out
um and he he employed he had like a
whole software company that employed
like 200 people something like that
um and he he even would say he dropped
out of college because it just didn't
make any sense and this was you know
when College wasn't as liberal and woke
as it is now
my dad used to say he's like let's say
you go to college and become a lawyer
you can make a YouTube channel talking
about law that makes 10 times more than
that lawyer for 10 times less work both
like you have to fuse with the internet
pure therapist like Dr K pulled on the
internet right
yeah no
um they will have a couple more
questions do you care if I do one or two
more I know you gotta go
yeah it'll work okay
um just do you know the apostolate
prophet David Wu or Sam shamoon
little no
um
Kosovo is Serbia Serbia number one who's
Kosovo
I don't know who that is uh who's the
Serbian influencer is there one
I don't know
um but
and then there's one last one John zurka
is blowing up let's go respect to Pearl
for bringing this Gem of a man pause
into the light keep up the great work
you two
um
yeah guys make sure you like the video
um thank you for coming on I appreciate
it I know we ran late today
yeah anytime you call we're gonna do a
lot of stuff together anytime you need
me I'll be on you're an out you're more
than an ally you're deeper than taped so
yeah yeah if you're ever in Chicago I'm
telling you you got a lot of content
that can film out here so let me know if
you're ever in town
yeah I'm back and forth I'm starting an
office like in Chicago so we're gonna
have like a Content house here and one
in London and then maybe more in the
future we'll see the first two go
that's great yeah next time I'm there
I'm gonna get baptized I'm gonna get
Nick there right to witness it so you
can say the n-word and uh yeah we'll do
stuff in Chicago and I've never been to
the windy windy place so I can't wait
okay well
um I don't actually know how to
okay yeah yeah in a second thanks for
coming on thanks for coming on um guys
like the video on your way out
um subscribe to the channel and let me
know in the comments who um we should
have on next uh the next interview like
the video subscribe to the